the foundation once tried to kill  scp-682 the hard-to-destroy reptile with  scp-272  an old iron nail this anomalous nail can  kill its victims in a number of ways the  nail binds a victim's shadow to the  ground indirectly binding the victim  itself as well by doing so if the shadow  is displaced due to changes in light  source the victim is flung and contorted  in the same direction the shadow has  moved if the victim tries to destroy the  nail they will surely die after the  foundation intentionally made the lights  in 682's chambers strobe on and off from  various directions causing the reptile  to be mutilated by being hurled around  the room its body began producing an  extremely powerful light source  eliminating its own shadow and keeping  it safe the light was so bright that  when d-classes entered the chamber to  remove the nail despite wearing eye  protection they were afflicted with  permanent retinal damage and of course  in the end  scp-682 was just fine